what's the difference between the main
character's wound and flaw
they're they're interconnected they're
the wound and the flaw is interconnected
something that
I recognize the story was the flaw is
the story of the wound and with that
recognition I
saw how strategy wise a lot of stories
are starting with the flaw in its
shining Glory the value in starting with
the flaw is that you are curious about
the wound you don't have the answer to
what the wound is
but you are curious why is the character
the way they are and then by the climax
we're getting a fuller view of the wound
so the difference is the wound is what
happens to the character that creates
the void the flaw is
how we see it come out how the character
is escaping the wound through
distraction through destructive Behavior
with the flaw
right because if I think back to Emily
the criminal she talked about living
with her grandmother yes so it hints
like something she wasn't raised by her
parents yes so we knew
right yes so we don't totally know yes
but we're wondering you know why did she
have these series of events that
happened and then I think it doesn't
come out right away so again your it
keeps you hooked it's the puzzle and
knowing how to strategize the puzzle
is everything and and writers need to
recognize that it's all a journey the
same thing like when you think about the
transformation
with falling in love how when we first
fall in love we don't know enough about
romantic love to know how to be to know
exactly what and we're in this
continuous learning process and and it
it is the same thing with the idea of
this transformation where we are you
don't just know what to do with story
you don't just know oh this is how I'm
going to break it up and this is what
the strategy is the more that you study
Story the more that you live Story the
more that you feel stored worry your
mind starts to see it in a depth that
you never knew was possible until you
get there
and what's great is when you talk about
falling in love so many characters I'm
just thinking back to like swingers or
or any Christmas movie where it's like
someone's been jilted or they've been
quote unquote abandoned no one's calling
yes and in in obsessing over that person
they then meet someone new yes who then
later on it pays off where that
abandoner calls and they don't need them
anymore exactly interesting that's
exactly right it it is all in the
transformation and when we look at our
life and like in my own personal Arc I
look at when I went through two defining
moments that sold my book storyline
finding gold in your life story and
change your story change your life it
had to do with a long relationship that
ended in a short marriage early on in
life and then a TR a career trajectory
that was interrupted and in looking at
if those two moments hadn't happened I
wouldn't have found what I view as the
love of my life for the last nine years
I wouldn't have met him unless those two
negative things happened in my life so I
think the the object of story is to
teach people when bad things happen
there is a greater purpose as it links
to the healing of the earlier wound and
as it links to the overall growth in the
life process and because so many of us
in life when we're in the heat of our
All Is Lost moments aren't ready for
that awareness story is continuously
making us conscious of that awareness
and do you think that in a good story
that that always lost moment has to then
resurface slated on Down the Line once
things are quote unquote better for the
character to really test them I don't
think always I think it works
tremendously if it's done well
I think always would make story too
formulaic and too predictable
so I think if it's done in a creative
way where we see the Dilemma in a
different light now that the character
has done the emotional work through the
action obstacle stake sequence and
at the climax you're at a place of did
they or didn't they
come into the transformation through the
recognition of the flaw then yes
so looking at that does every
protagonist need a goal
absolutely
if there's one thing in story you just
nailed the most important thing in Story
the goal is everything the the external
goal as well as the internal goal the
understanding of the want versus the
need and the recognition
that often the character wants something
externally
that isn't in the transformed thinking
of the mindset things that we talked
about with the idea of survival mindset
intuitive mindset and intellectual
mindset so the goal is the goal is your
if you don't know what the character
wants the story doesn't work and knowing
that is the character going to get what
they want externally or are they going
to get it internally is what keeps the
audience interested in the story
do you ever say to writers I feel like
the goal for your character the stakes
need to be risen it's not
it's not not important enough but it's
just it doesn't seem like it would would
be sensible for most people all the time
Stakes is something the dream
is
an aha moment that I had in my study of
story when you set the dream up at the
beginning the dream sets up the stakes
when we know what the character wants
and why they want it through the dream
then we get a glimpse of the internal
and the external Stakes so the dream is
a pivotal tool in the setup that can
make all the difference in the world
with feeling the stakes
so is that something that you see
sometimes with new writers that their
goal it's too small of a goal you need
to really like up the ante yes and that
goes into the idea of what a question I
ask all the time is what is the worst
that can happen if the goal is not
achieved and that means that if the
answer is
they could you know Miss going on a date
or they could something so small that in
the bigger scheme of things doesn't feel
like a life and death type of scenario
then it's not working
do you ever recommend people do like a q
a with their character yes I do in story
therapy that's interesting you ask that
question excellent question the in story
therapy I have a whole set of questions
that I give writers that is the idea of
understanding the character's awareness
of what's holding them back of what
happened in the past of what do they
want and getting to know your character
by having this type of interview with
your character
and then two it seems like then the
characters would really come out more if
you're if you're doing this like
interview yeah with your character it
seems like almost you would you would it
would become more and more real to you
oh yeah that I think the writer knowing
the character and feeling the character
from the inside is
so important with how the audience is
going to experience the character uh
something I recognize that a lot of
Writers Do Is they give the wound to the
wrong character
so we'll end up knowing more about a
supporting character than we will about
the central character
and when that happens then we're going
what do we know about the central
character why don't we feel the same
type of poem we start to go why isn't it
the other character's story
since the other character has more to
lose with the stakes
because we know their wound
another thing that I'm seeing a lot of
stories do which is fantastic is they
are developing the wound for the
antagonist
in more depth than they have and as long
as the
protagonists we feel their wound in at a
high level and you parallel so you have
a strategy with the wound of the
antagonist then it can work really well
is there a danger in the writer
identifying too much with the
protagonist
because it's like too precious to them
if they if the lines are blurred and
it's like well essentially this is
really me yeah is there a danger in that
yes
because of exactly what you might think
when the character is too much like them
and they feel like I wouldn't do that
yet
dramatically it doesn't work in the
story and that that has to do with like
writers who are telling story from an
autobiographical angle versus an angle
of emotional truth when they're telling
a story from an autobiographical angle
they get stuck on the idea of well that
didn't happen
well that didn't happen without
recognizing that life doesn't happen in
dramatic structure